did you see that Python that they found
in the middle of the Everglades it was
17 feet long oh my I was so I grew that
I saw this there's one thing that I was
talking about exotic pets I googled it
they get to 30 feet long I can't even
understand that that is ridiculous then
so then I went down a hole I did I saw
the Python hole the record record 17
footlong Python carrying 73 eggs
captioned Flores Everglades
another reason we should just get rid of
Florida snap it off and push it into the
ocean there's too much craziness
happening there that fucking snake now
here's the thing that freaked me out I
found out those snakes get twice that
length ah so this has only been going on
apparently for like the last 15 or so
years they apparently didn't have a real
population of pythons in the Everglades
15 years ago did somebody's pet get
loose that thing at 73 eggs oh no no it
didn't get loose some asshole just
released his snake someone just chucked
it out the window and then it fucks up
the balance of the ecosystem they
escaped from a breeding facility
destroyed by Hurricane Andrew in 1992
well that makes sense
a hundred percent how horror movie
starts great horror movie somebody write
that script tens of thousands of Burmese
pythons are estimated now be living in
the area and that's just now they've
completely wiped out all the raccoons
all the skunk's all the rabbits no
matter how yeah they're eating
alligators now nice those things eat
alligators at the video to see dude shit
chick-fil-a there's a photograph of one
that died because the alligator chewed
its way out of its body nature is so
brutal it's so damn ruthless but there's
some beauty in that ruthlessness just
just that like undying desire for
survival that exists and creatures like
that that can't there's no empathy
there's no sympathy they're just gonna
eat their way out of you to survive yeah
there's something cool about as long as
it's not your five-year-old kid that
gets not salutely absolutely that's a
goddamn nightmare this show this but
that's just for you guys
she was just one doing a video one I
think this is an
Conda and a caiman says Python eats
alligator alive I mean it's the whole
thing alive is that a Python for sure oh
yeah it seems like it is seems like
that's actually a video of me eating a
grilled cheese and 2 a.m. it is sped up
but look how it gets all the way down to
the fucking tail that is amazing I
wonder if snakes have taste buds or if
it's just for pure hunger to just stop
and think about what we're looking at
here this fucking snake just ate a whole
alligator there goes a tail Oh his body
is just my god down look at that then
he's got to go away and chill because
they're vulnerable when they eat that
he's gonna go and just hide in a hide
under a canopy well that's why there's
not sheiks everywhere on earth well now
there are in Florida yeah but I mean
they're not everywhere because if they
they really could just eat and then go
out and eat again like real quick like
how a lion could write it would be they
would eat all the ecosystem would be
destroyed
they'd eat up everything where the
alligator chewed its way out also kind
of badass of that alligator
it looks like the tail popped out yeah
maybe the tail you know cuz those tails
are very strong and they're so thick
it's like an armor go to that website
that's wild
Jesus that is really wild but that's
just shows you how hungry these fucking
things are they've eaten everything
that's out there but also their masters
their their ability to capture something
and then kill it that's that vicious you
brought an alligator like those are kind
of hard to sneak up on and capture and
hold on to I don't think they are I
think you don't think so no I think
that's one of the reasons why it could
get it so quick I think they just lay
around most of the time I think
alligators don't tweak because they
don't have any natural enemies until the
pythons came along because they're so
badass yeah I don't think they're
equipped for this yeah they're probably
not equipped for your pie right where
they're just there the snake found a
vulnerability in the system he was like
I'm gonna snack on alligators wonder how
long it takes a snake with his nasty gut
juices to break down alligator hide
three three three days three to four
days that's my guess I must say at least
a week to break down all that
maybe even longer yeah it's got to have
some gnarly like massive acids in its
stomach to break that down yeah some
shit like from the movie alien yes like
battery acid huh
it just burns right through it why
aren't we like using snake acid to break
down rust on cars and stuff we should be
looking into that yeah I would clean up
everything I would set up everything an
animated recreation of the Python
alligator battle suggests that the
Python might have survived its massive
meal but that a second Gator came to the
rescue and bit off the snake's head Oh
was that the alligators bitch being like
no the force of the tussle the new
theory says is what caused the Python
last whoa so our alligator came and
fucked him I hate alligator home he came
in rescued they have any homies really
no assholes I think they're assholes
with tiny little brains and they just
chew things and suck them down they just
fuck reptilian style did you ever see
that video of the crocodiles and they go
to feed them and it was on my Instagram
Jamie that one with the crocodile well
this person goes to throw some chicken
out for the crocodiles and the
crocodiles snap up the chicken and one
crocodile reaches over to the guy next
to him and bites his leg Oh
bites the crocodiles leg and his roll oh
god snaps it off and strikes it down
swallows it and the other alligator the
other crocodile rather doesn't even
budge oh he just got his arm bit off
he's like what happened oh my fuck this
is when you realize what these things
are they don't give a fuck there's it's
so crazy to watch their dinosaurs
doesn't even freak out that it's arm got
bitten off and swallowed by his name
well I will say if I'm eating a really
delicious sandwich and someone bites me
imma be like I'm just gonna finish the
sandwich I have to be honest how hungry
are you if you're very hungry
well he's not even finishing he's lying
there and the other out or the other
crocodile bites his leg and then rips it
off watch this that's shit just watch it
boom now watch they've run in see this
one's snacking up and grabs it now watch
Gator roll Jeff snaps it off and I watch
Chuck sit down cool but look at him he
doesn't even do anything what the fuck
bro
he just lost his leg and he's like what
the fuck bro I mean those are not
regenerative right yes they are
can he grow another paw whoa yeah they
grow other paws all the time that's yeah
that is so wild well that's like some
Gator DNA in my face I bet yeah that's
really good for just like keeping your
shit fresh or you look like scales you
want that that'd be kind of cool forever
scales I'd be a superhero I could
probably capitalize on it but what you
look like right just no scales to your
face solutely
to them right now I'm not gonna wear any
Roos I got scales I'm gonna go out some
girl had to be the first girl to get a
face tattoo you could be the first girl
to get scales probably some probably
really long time ago
someone's got a face tattoo well most
tribal yeah most likely try definitely a
tribal maybe like one of those
polyandrous tribes
what is this Jamie it looks like a snake
with alligator inside of it yeah it does
take three days for it to break down
scientists doctors coming into your lane
better watch out I'm a doctor and a
scientist know all about acid I know
about acids because I'm Italian I've got
a Judah that's the Cillian science guys
get the fucking idea Kenny you know
meatballs they give me the odd Judah huh
you know what's crazy about the
Everglades is if this is how it is now
imagine what its gonna be like 20 years
from now these things just keep reading
yeah it's gonna take it's gonna take a
few generations for that to balance back
out they need to put some wolves in that
area and get it all back to where it
should be well they have crocodiles in
there No - there's been confirmed
sightings of Nile crocodiles not
American crocodiles Nile crocodiles for
the same reason that's wild
where the alligators are yeah that's
fucked yeah it's fucked because those
are the ones that eat zebras and shit
yeah they're gonna everything they're
gonna be eating that watch hide your
kids hide your wife yeah they don't
definitely